- Are you ready?
- We're ready!
- Yeah!
- Let's go!
- Nina's having fun. Go, Nina! Woo!
- Yay! Happy birthday to me. (laughs)
- Good morning!
- Welcome to day four.
- Is it day four?
- Day four. Heading off
to the Magic Kingdom!
And we also need to sing something.
♫ Happy birthday to you.
(Nina laughs)
Guys. ♫ Happy birthday to you.
- [All] ♫ Happy birthday dear...
- [Kids] Auntie.
- [Evan] Nina.
♫ Happy birthday to you.
Hey! It's Nina's birthday! We're
going to have a magical day.
On our first day at Walt Disney World.
No, Magic Kingdom, Magic Kingdom.
(soft piano music)
Okay, it is a cold day today in Florida.
What, the high of 60?
- [Nina] 60.
- 60.
- 60, which is 16. 60
Fahrenheit, 16 Celsius.
- [Nina] It's 14.
- No, it's not even 14,
now. It's like 9 right now.
Yeah, it's cold, but it's warming up.
It's okay. Better than
what's happening in Toronto.
Are we ready to have a what day?
What kind of day are we going to have?
- [Nina] Magic.
- [Hayden] A magical day!
- [Evan] Alright. Let's go.
- With super-Hayden, the wizard!
- [Evan] Alright, I like it.
Okay, this way. Let's go.
(upbeat music)
Alright. Nina's going to go
take the kids to Aladdin,
and I am going to go get her a coffee.
A special birthday coffee to warm up.
- Yeah, it's cold.
- I'm going to get a
coffee for myself, too.
Okay, bye kids! Go with
Nina, go with Nina!
(elegant music)
Alright. Got the coffees.
Venti caramel macchiato for Nina,
venti green tea matcha...latte for me.
That was a crazy-long lineup.
Nina went on one ride with the kids
and is on the second ride with the kids.
The lineup at Starbucks is longer than
the lineups to go at the
rides at Walt Disney World.
That's the world we live in.
Well, Nina's going to be
happy, it's her birthday,
she needs a warm drink,
so that's how we do it.
Look who I found! How was it?
- Good! Good.
- [Evan] So you went on this
ride, Aladdin, which I missed.
And then you went on Jungle
Cruise, which I missed.
But we got Nina her coffee!
I don't know if that's yours,
actually. I think it is.
And how is it? Was it worth it?
- Mm.
- [Evan] Yummy!
Alright, let's keep going.
(upbeat guitar music)
Nina's excited. Why?
- Because it's warm.
- [Evan] Because it's warm
in here. We're in for a show.
I wasn't allowed to film in there,
but did we have a good time?
(Hayden singing)
In the Tiki, Tiki, Tiki, Tiki,
Tiki Room. That was good.
(Hayden singing)
Let's see what's next.
(fiddle music)
We're ready to watch some bears.
Birthday girl is all excited.
Hayden is all excited.
Nina wants a P-U-P-P-Y
for her birthday present.
- P-U-P-P-Y (Nina laughs)
- [Hayden] P-U! P-P! Y!
- But she has me.
- You are my P-U-P-P-Y.
- Right? We don't need to get a puppy.
We need a puppy, people? You've got me.
- [Hayden] Yeah. He's
also not potty trained.
- I am potty trained.
(Nina laughs)
Okay? Puppy may not be potty trained,
but Evan is potty trained.
Very well potty trained.
- Hayden is potty trained.
- There's no issues there.
(fiddle music)
(upbeat guitar music)
Okay, guys. Everybody huddle in.
I have two questions for you.
One: We having fun today?
- Mm-hmm
- Yep.
- Yeah.
- Okay. Second question.
Oh, I've got three questions.
Second question: Is it cold today?
- Yeah!
- Huh.
- Little bit.
- Third question: Does that mean
it's too cold for ice cream today?
- [Stephanie] No!
- [Nina] Yes.
(Evan laughs)
- Nina's yawning a lot today.
Happy birthday, yawner.
Next up, Pirates of the Caribbean!
(swashbuckling music)
Hayden's getting a
little too big for this.
(pirate shouts, audience cheers)
He's getting a little too big for this.
Maybe this is the last year.
I'm getting a massage after this.
(swashbuckling music)
- More like two horns. Ah!
- [Evan] What did we think?
- Awesome!
- Time to go eat some lunch, yeah!
(bright music)
- [Evan] It's lunch time.
The boys have chicken strips. How is it?
- Good.
- [Evan] Stephanie, how's
the bacon cheeseburger?
Yummy. We've got fries and apple slices,
and we both have chicken
cheeseburgers, too.
Time to eat up! Yum, yum!
(bright music)
So, everybody's very cold.
- I'm freezing.
- So we're going to spend some
time inside at the laugh floor
hearing some jokes and having
a good time and getting warm.
To get in here, we've got
to get into this line.
I snuck out, trying to get
Nina coffee at Starbucks
to just warm her up. Warm her
hands up, warm her insides.
Because she's freezing.
But, lineup out the door.
So, I think we'll spend
more time in that lineup
than in the Monsters, Inc. line, so--
Nina, we're going inside.
Nina's happy. Is it warm?
- Yes!
- [Evan] Alright, it's warm.
(comedic music)
- They're playing bachata.
You want to dance? Bachata.
I like the bachata.
(whimsical music)
- [Evan] What was your favorite part?
- The fireworks.
- Came back to Starbucks.
The lineup's not that bad.
(piano music)
Here's Nina! Here's Nina!
She's back! How we doing?
- Your green tea latte. I got a coffee.
- [Evan] Thank you.
(crowd noise)
How do you feel?
- Warm.
(upbeat music)
- Hayden has been a crazy
driver the last time we came on.
You going to drive better?
- Yeah!
- You sure?
- Yes.
- Yes!
(exciting music)
- [Evan] Are you ready?
- Yes!
- [Evan] You ready?
- [Evan] You ready?!
- Yes!
- [Evan] Alright.
- Are you ready?
- You ready?
- Yes!
- Let's go!
Here's the thing, Hayden.
- What?
- Here's what I didn't tell you.
I'm in charge of gas, and
you're in charge of steering.
But I never take my foot off the gas.
It's all go! Alright?
This is the worst driving ever! (laughs)
Look at how we're driving!
(exciting music)
(Evan and Hayden laughing)
- [Evan] Eyes on the
road! Hands on the wheel!
We're alive, barely.
Barely, barely.
Was that fun? Huh?
- Yeah.
- Yeah? High five, mister.
Boom! Good job.
(elegant music)
- [Evan] Nina's having fun. Go, Nina! Woo!
What do you think, Stephanie?
Nice. Hayden, what do you think? Nice.
(upbeat music)
We're going to have my favorite ice cream.
It's a twist, vanilla and
orange flavor together.
Oh, yeah. Get it--
Nina, Nina likes to photobomb my shots.
Nina's the photobomber, but we love her,
and it's her birthday, so it's all good.
Ice cream time!
(bright music)
- [Evan] Are you guys ready
for the last ride of the day?
- [Kids] Yes.
- [Evan] What are we going to do?
- Buzz--
- [Evan] Buzz Lightyear!
- Toy Story--
- [Evan] Toy Story!
Let's go beat the Emperor Zerg! Ooh-rah!
(gentle music)
Nina has a special message
for Believe Nation.
- Believe.
- [Evan] Believe, that's a good message.
Okay, so, Nina's going to
do a rematch with Hayden.
Nina wins every year, but maybe
this is the year Hayden takes over.
And, Stephanie and Jeffery are going to
battle each other out in their own car.
This is a two handed game, so...
I'm not going to film.
I'm competitive; I need
to beat all these chumps.
(Nina laughs)
Got to beat all these chumps.
So, I'm not going to film once we get in,
but I'm predicting a victory. We'll see.
(bright music)
It's go time. Go time!
Alright, final score: 224,400.
Let's see how they'll-- 224,000.
We'll see.
How much did you get?
- She got...
1,000...
- [Evan] 1,000?
- 400 and something,
and I got 1,800 and something.
- [Evan] 1,000?!
- 18,000, 18,000.
- [Evan] There's--
(crowd noise)
- [Evan] Where am I?
Oh yeah, there is the game face.
Look at the game face.
How much did you score?
- 18,000.
- [Evan] You got 18,000?
- He got 18,000.
And what did you get?
- I got 1-4-4-0-0. 14,400.
- [Evan] You got 14,000? What did you get?
- Huh? 2,800.
- [Evan] 2,000! What did Jeffery get?
- 2,000 and seven.
- [Evan] Alright.
I don't think I want to say what I got.
- [Hayden] What did you get?
- I'm not saying what I got.
- [Hayden] Tell me!
- [Evan] I'm not saying what I got.
You don't want to know what I got.
- [Hayden] Tell me, please.
- I think Nina won. It's her birthday.
- Please tell me.
- [Evan] You really want to know?
- Yes. I really--
- I really want to know.
- [Evan] I got 224,000
- What?!
- Yeah, but you know what?
My machine was probably
broken or something.
- Hah!
- Thank you guys so much for joining us.
Day four, Disney trip.
Hope you had fun watching us having fun.
We'll do it again, join us for day five.
Thank you so much, continue to believe!
Or whatever your one word is. And--
- We'll see you soon!
- Oh, wow, Nina jumping in.
She's totally stealing
the spotlight, this Nina.
Well, it's her birthday.
Wish Tina "Happy Birthday"
in the comments, too.
She deserves a happy birthday.
See you guys.